American Horror Story has covered plenty of
terrifying ground, so there are bound to have
been some huge hits, and some big misses,
along the way.
Here are some of the best and worst episodes
of Ryan Murphy's horror anthology juggernaut.
American Horror Story broke onto the scene
with Murder House, a traditional haunted house
story of a dysfunctional family who unwittingly
move into a doomed new home.
The Harmon family are trying to weather plenty
of family issues, including Ben's affair and
Vivien's miscarriage, and encounter a number
of odd neighbors, including the brooding Tate
and the controlling Constance, as they uncover
the dark history of the house.
"Why'd you move here?"
"My dad had an affair…
My mom literally caught him in the act."
"That's horrible."
In "Piggy, Piggy," the season's sixth episode,
one specific mystery is solved: It turns out
Tate is not a neighbor at all, but a ghost
who resides in the house.
Tate, however, is unaware that he is dead,
and audiences are introduced to Billie Dean
Howard, a medium who can help him with this
discovery.
In classic AHS tradition, the episode is jam-packed,
including a revelation that Vivien is pregnant
with the Antichrist and a subplot involving
one of Ben's troubled psychiatry patients,
but the emotional core remains with Violet
and Tate, who confess their love for one another
and stand by each other through each frightening
realization that they encounter.
Though it wasn't immediately obvious that
Cult would focus on the 2016 election, Murphy
announced the inspiration before it aired,
setting audiences up for what was sure to
be a polarizing season.
With regulars Sarah Paulson and Evan Peters
taking the helm as a "liberal snowflake" and
a power-hungry right-winger, respectively,
the season had a strong concept…
Unfortunately, in standard American Horror
Story fashion, it tried a little too hard
to juggle too much, including more unnerving
neighbors, a succession of influential cult
leaders, a roving band of killer clowns, and
more.
The seventh episode of the seventh season,
"Valerie Solanas Died For Your Sins, Scumbag,"
utilizes a relatively clumsy flashback to
feminist figure Valerie Solanas, who shot
Andy Warhol in 1968 at the Factory as an act
of rebellion.
"Who are you kidding?
Shooting me will be the only thing you'll
be remembered for.
I am your legacy."
Though this did actually happen, and Solanas
was a real person, the script takes some fairly
wild liberties with her story, suggesting
that, somehow, she was responsible for all
of the Zodiac Killer correspondence.
Yeah, it was kind of a big mess, and all its
muddled story beats made for an unsatisfying
episode.
One of the more whimsical seasons of the show,
the third season of American Horror Story
focuses on a coven led by Fiona Goode, played
by Jessica Lange, the ruling Supreme who will
do anything to hold onto her throne.
Meanwhile, the young witches in Fiona's coven
attend a unique Academy, with Goode's daughter
Cordelia acting as headmistress.
Throughout the season, each witch hones her
powers, wielding them against outside forces
while fine-tuning them in the hopes of becoming
the next Supreme.
The season premiere, "Bitchcraft," gives viewers
a perfect introduction to the season's enormous
coterie of characters, which will only grow
throughout the season, setting up the fight
for Supreme, as well as introducing us to
a couple of truly terrifying villains.
Throughout all of this setup, the premiere
doesn't feel clumsy or expositional, but rather,
like it's prepping viewers for the emotional,
and pulse-pounding, rollercoaster we've been
waiting for.
"Jesus, Sabrina, relax.
We're just messing with you."
Though Coven was a positively received season,
and it began with a proverbial bang, it ended
with a whimper.
With the season building to one question,
who will be the next Supreme?, the coven of
witches are all prepared to battle it out
for the title.
As each witch makes her way through the tests,
she's stumped by one element or another.
In the end, Cordelia winds up coming through
as the Supreme… which, after pitting the
girls against each other all season, feels
utterly underwhelming, and a little bit like
a cop-out.
"Having fun yet?"
"Yeah, it's a real party."
Even an appearance by Stevie Nicks, who opens
the episode with a short impromptu music video,
can't save this lukewarm finale, which culminates
in Fiona finding herself trapped in her own
personal hell, being stuck in an old farmhouse
for eternity with her former lover, the Axeman.
Watching Jessica Lange frantically scream
about the house's foundations does elicit
some chuckles, but, as a whole, this ending
doesn't do any service to the rollercoaster
of a season that preceded it.
When it comes to American Horror Story, it's
not uncommon for a season to premiere strong…
only to start losing steam as plots become
more and more convoluted and characters come
and go.
Freak Show is no exception, even though the
season ranks quite low among the others, "Monsters
Among Us" is a standout episode in its own
right.
Audiences meet Elsa Mars, played by Jessica
Lange in her final full season of American
Horror Story, as she rescues conjoined twins
Bette and Dot from a hospital, only to place
them in her freak show.
The episode also seamlessly introduces Twisty,
a terrifying, murderous clown, as well as
socialite Gloria Mott and her deranged son
Dandy.
"How's that?"
"Better.
The seat's warm."
"Mother made it toasty for you."
Gross.
Anyway, to cap it all off, Elsa performs a
David Bowie song, the aptly named "Life on
Mars," to be precise, to close out the episode,
and reveals her own secret: she's a double
amputee.
The premiere of Freak Show is an excellent
example of a successful start: it expertly
sets up the the rest of the season, and despite
the lackluster episodes that follow, it remains
one of the standouts of the entire series.
Even though it had an extraordinarily strong
start, Freak Show, much like its predecessor
Coven, ended with a fizzle.
Most of the finale focuses on Elsa herself,
who moves to Hollywood and marries an executive,
but allows herself to be escorted to the afterlife
by the ghost of Edward Mordrake, who kills
any freak that performs on Halloween.
Why?
Because American Horror Story, that's why!
"The day of reckoning is here."
"It hurts… but only for a moment."
In her final performance, she sings David
Bowie's "Heroes," before being gently escorted
back to the freak show, where her deceased
brethren are waiting with open arms.
Though it seems like a fairly warm and happy
ending to such a violent season, it not only
leaves plenty of narrative threads in the
dust, it's also a straight-up dull closing
to an arc that once held so much promise.
Unlike Asylum, which provides closure by giving
Lana Winters one last act of revenge, Freak
Show pretends it's giving viewers a satisfying
ending, when ultimately it looks more like
the showrunners weren't sure where to go with
such a challenging and off-the-wall season.
"The sins of the living don't add up to much
around here.
In life, we play the parts we're cast in."
It's consistently ranked as the best season
of the entire series, so it's difficult to
choose the best episode of Asylum.
The finale, in which Lana Winters takes her
revenge on her murderous son and triumphs
by force of sheer will, was a strong contender,
but the top spot has to go to "Name Game,"
if only for the trippy, out-of-place dance
sequence starring Jessica Lange from which
the episode takes its title.
Yeah, it's a wacky one in all the right ways.
This episode is a perfect showcase for the
best of everything that American Horror Story
has to offer; sheer fantasy, indelible images,
and dramatic moments; including a touching
turn by Frances Conroy as the Angel of Death,
who arrives to collect the dead throughout
the episode.
When it's at the top of its game, the show
looks a lot like this: a love letter to both
camp and horror, while still letting each
character experience real, human moments that
remind us of why we fell in love with it in
the first place.
"Wanted to say goodbye."
"Goodbye?"
"I'm going to Rome."
If Asylum is frequently ranked as the best
season of American Horror Story, then Hotel,
which usually falls to the bottom of the pack,
is its direct inverse.
The season is based loosely on several hotel-related
horror stories, including H.H. Holmes' murderous
hotel, where the serial killer kept his victims
during the 1893 World's Fair in Chicago, and
the 2013 disappearance of Elisa Lam at L.A.'s
Cecil Hotel.
With Jessica Lange's exit at the end of the
previous season, the show had yet another
hurdle to overcome, who would serve as the
leading lady, and though Lady Gaga offered
up an admirably campy turn as the vampiric
Countess, it couldn't save an uneven season
that tried a little too hard and muddled its
own story time and time again.
After all, would it even be American Horror
Story if it didn't have too many arcs and
way, way too many unlikable characters?
"Who the hell are you people?"
The premiere remains the worst episode of
what many viewers consider one of the worst
seasons, if only for its best known scene:
a violent sequence during which Gabriel, played
by New Girl's Max Greenfield, is sodomized
by a monster known as the "Addiction Demon."
Critics and fans alike viewed this as exploitative
and unnecessary, and it became clear that
while American Horror Story was usually a
guilty pleasure, this season might be abandoning
the word "pleasure" entirely.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.